guys i love the story
mike pillow mike lindell the ceo of
mypillow
he was just finishing up giving a speech
in colorado
and he was served with a lawsuit on
camera this is
i love this the i relish this
is it schadenfreude schadenfraud ah
every time i say it someone emails me
and says david you're pronouncing it
wrong
you guys know exactly what i'm talking
about as mike pillow is walking away
from a speech about election integrity
in colorado
he gets served by eric coomer's
defamation lawsuit eric coomer is this
former employee of dominion voting
systems pillow has been hammering on
coomer for a while and uh the best part
about this video is initially pillow
doesn't realize he's being served
legally here and he tries to kind of
walk away and says he doesn't want the
papers then he realizes he's been served
and he looks dejected and he sounds
dejected and i love it i really do take
a look at this video listen to the audio
thank you mike thank you for everything
what is this sure
sir what is this
it's for you okay well what is not for
me it's not for me
hey i i need you to open it that is
right there soon
it's always nice to have video evidence
of proof of service
sue all these guys if the facts point
that way sue every single one of them
and it's i don't know if this is even a
guilty pleasure of mine
but you really love to see it and i
don't know that mike pillow realizes the
amount of trouble that he's in
this really could destroy him
financially he has a lot of money i know
it really could
sydney powell the other uh
she was i guess she still is a lawyer
even though she's been disbarred a bunch
of places she was pushing a lot of these
bogus frivolous legal complaints around
the 2020 election i'm
you never hear me say
sue them
i i say
sue them if the evidence points to it
and it seems that the evidence points to
lawsuits against mike pillow and one of
the things that again we talk about
projection the right generally speaking
it's the right that says
we need tort reform
we which often by
tort reform they mean we need to make it
more difficult for individuals
to be able to hold corporations
accountable you have to understand in
general when they when the right talks
about tort reform they mean let's make
it easier for corporations to do
whatever the hell they want
and make it more difficult for them to
be held accountable
they talk all the time about frivolous
lawsuits frivolous oh this lawsuit's
frivolous that lawsuit is frivolous
courts can determine that courts have
courts are very well equipped to
determine whether a lawsuit should or
shouldn't move forward and if it
shouldn't they dismiss lawsuits and one
of the things that was found by courts
is that they were filing the frivolous
lawsuits and frivolous legal complaints
in the aftermath of the 2020 election
and if they've done it in a way that is
systematic and is a waste of the court's
time
100 percent hold them accountable
pillow's getting sued again and he's got
a big legal bill coming and something
about that video that video is from
marshall zellinger with nine news really
good job of of zellinger was just there
and he happened to get the process uh
server delivering the papers it's just
fantastic
he has got a big uphill legal battle in
front of him and of course he continues
to claim pillow does
that were like days from
the evidence coming out or whatever
it's wacky these people are bonkers and
unfortunately a lot of their followers
believe every word they say so we'll
track this lawsuit
but you really love to see that clip if
you didn't if you're listening today and
you're not watching you can see the
delivery of the papers we'll have it on
our instagram at david pakman show
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple
people are busy we're not always getting
effective balanced nutrition from the
food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us ag-1
by athletic greens is a delicious drink
that just simplifies the entire thing
it's one product you get all of the
things you need 75 vitamins minerals and
whole food sourced ingredients it's a
multivitamin it's a multi mineral it's a
probiotic green food blend
in one daily serving really easy high
quality bio available ingredients can
fill those nutritional gaps in your diet
and they can help with gut health and
digestion and support you in other ways
and they can replace multiple products
and pills that you might be taking it's
just one drink really simple i've been
enjoying the ag-1 drink by athletic
greens tastes good helps me get
everything i'm trying to get athletic
greens is giving my audience a free
one-year supply of vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman the link is in the podcast notes